[موسيقى]
مساكم الله بالخير
عندي اليوم تحدي صعب
قالوا انت تتكلم في العمل الانساني وفي
التطوع وتطلع في دميدان وغاثه وزلازل
وحروب نبغاك تبكي الناس عن وجه واحد يبكي
بالله بس قلت اي شيء حزين ابكوا عشان بس
احقق لهم طلبهم خلاص اتفقنا طيب مساكم
الله بالخير 2017 كان في تدكس هنا في
جامعه الامير سلطان
كنت حاضر لرجل راقي هذاك الرجل كان عنده
برزنتيشن حلو تدرون وش فيه حوض وسمك
ذهبيه تسبح عشر ثواني تروح السمكه وترجع
الظاهر المقطع قاعد يروح ويرجع العيد
واحنا مفكرها تسبح ما وقفت طول المقطع
طبعا عشر دقايق بعد عشر دقائق هذي اكتشفنا
انه السمكه الذهبيه اللي تسبح هذه كانت
مليانه قيم ومبادئ كثيره تعلمناها في
حياتنا من العشر دقائق ومن السمكه الذهبيه
هذيك خلص هذاك الرجل ونزل وجلس جنبي هو
صاحب بنكته جميله قال لي ها اعرف اسولف
قلت ما شاء الله عليك خوش صراحه بس سوالف
ما فيه زيك قال يلا المره هذه انت حضرتي
المره الجايه بحضر لك انا طبعا صاحب
الكلام
الطيب هذا كان المرحوم نجيب الزامل الله
يغفر له ويرحمه
العم نجيب
انا احترمه كثير لانه قدم لي في حياتي
كثير له فضل علي كثير انا اليوم متوتر
تدرون ليه
لانه قال لي ابغى احضر لك حملني مسؤوليه
كبيره هو ما حضر لكنه حضر فيني
حظر فيني لانه اعطاني تذكره رحله السفر
الى المعنى رحله البحث الى المعنى خلى
حياتي فيها معنى استحق ان اعيش لاجل هذا
المعنى
اليوم انا ماني جاي اتكلم
يعطيكم تذكره سفر لعالم الحياه شهاده
جامعيه ولا علم ولا معرفه لا انا جاي
اليوم احكي لكم تجارب انا مريت فيها خلتني
اسعى واحرص ان حياتي كلها قيمه
في اول تجربه لي في ميدان العمل الانساني
كنت اتفلسف متحمس ابغى اروح زي بعض شركات
السياحه الهادفه هذه اللي تروح تخليك تروح
مدرسه ولا تروح اي مكان ولا مزرعه وتسوي
عمل انساني نبيل بسيط كذا وتصور وترجع
ومتحمس ابغى اسوي ابغى اقدم كل شيء
فدخلت في احد
الفصول الخاصه للدعم النفسي للاطفال وشفت
الاطفال قاعدين يرسمون وقعدت اقول يلا
ارسم يا عمو ارسم يا عمو شيء حلو ارسم شيء
ارسم صح فكان في قلم اسود يرسم فيه هذاك
الطفل باستمرار رسم البيت رسم الشمس ربع
الدائره واستمر بالرسم باللون الاسود كان
يرسم باستمرار فكنت اجي اقول يا عمو ارسم
صح لون الرسمه يا عمو فرحت وجيت قلت ها يا
عمو ما يصير ورده سوداء ورده
شمس سوداء ما يصير تبغى اساعدك
قال ايه يا عمو انت بتحكي ارسم صح انا عم
برسم بيتنا في سوريا احنا بيتنا احترق انت
ما شفت الشمس سوداء ما شفت الشمس سوداء
خطا عظيم
فزعه وفنان وبتعمل الانسان كان خطا عظيم
في حياتي ليش لانه كان في بعد نفسي عند
المختصين قاعدين يسوونه التعامل مع الناس
بالفيلد بالميدان كان يحتاج الى سكيلز
ومهارات معينه ومبادئ معينه لازم الشخص
يتعلم كيف ان هو يتعامل مع الناس في
الميدان
قررت انا في في هذيك السفره اني اخذ العمل
بطريقه احترافيه ما اكون بس ابغى اخلي
حياتي لها معنى خلاص قالوا الناس المؤثرين
خليك فاروق الزمان وقال لنا كلام حلو
وواجه بالكلام الايجابي ترى الكلام اللي
قال كلام عميق ما هو خلاص قال لي بروح
انفذ لا ترى هو عشان يوصل لمرحله هذه ترى
بذل جهد كبير في اشياء انت لازم تقدمها
عشان تتجاوز هذه المعوقات
فعلا انطلقت في في رحلتي في البحث عن
المعنى المعنى ان اكون انسان له قيمه
اكتشفت انه اول شيء لازم اتعلمه عشان
انطلق واخلي حياتي لها معنى اني اتعرف على
مين انا اتعرف على نفسي كيف اتعرف على
نفسي
بالتفاصيل كل التفاصيل المواقف اللي تمر
في حياتي ترى رحله البحث عن المعنى
الطويله ما لها محطه ما لها محطه نهايه
انا لسه في الرحله هذه ما راح اوصل
هي اكثر محطه في العالم فيها محطات
ترانزيت اليوم محطه ترانزيت تروح تتعشى
ترى محطه ترانزيت ترى ما هي رحله جويه ولا
بريه انت قاعد انت في رحله الحياه قاعد
تتوقف في محطات ترانزيت عشان تبحث عن نفسك
تجد نفسك تجد لنفسك قيمه في هذه الحياه
احنا لما نسافر اي دوله في العالم نكتشف
ان العالم هذا صحيح انه كبير لكنه صغير
مره واحد قال لي يا اخي تعامل معهم السنه
اندونيسي تتعامل مع شاب افريقي تتعامل مع
لاجئ سوري اكتشفت
اننا واحد هذا الانسان هو الانسان تختلف
العادات والتقاليد والثقافه اللغه كل شيء
لكن يبقى الانسان هو الانسان اليوم لما
جيت
بقدم احترت ابدا بايش قلت تدري يقول
السلام عليكم واللي يطلع يطلع ليش لاني
دخلت بالسلام السلام السلام كلمه عظيم
احنا امه سلام هذا الشيء اللي احنا قاعدين
نسويه بالفيل ترى احنا لما نروح اي دوله
بالعالم
ترى انا نروح برساله سلام برساله انسانيه
برساله حب وهذه يكسر كل الحواجز خلاص
وصلنا
اختصرت نصف الطريق
عشان كده احنا لما لما نقول العالم واحد
والانسان هو الانسان ما اختلفت الدوله
والديانه وهذه مبادئ العمل الانساني ترى
عدم التحيز والحيادي كلها تاخذك بطريقه
واحد الانسان هو الانسان
واما رحت انت تقدر تقدم تقدر تتواصل مهما
كانت الطريقه وانا اعتقد انه يعني الفقره
اللي بيتحدث فيها الاستاذ خالد صديقي
بيقول لها دلاله كبيره للكلام اللي انا
قاعد اقوله لان خالد لما يروح يسافر
السياحه او اي مكان في العالم ما يروح
الاماكن اللي
بيعيش فيها بطبيعته اللي هو قاعد يعيش
فيها هنا ترى يروح رحله خالد ماي واحد
يروح لما يركب قطار يومين من باكستان
للصين خالد انت مجنون سامح هذا بس اللي
قاعد تسوي الجنون هذا خلاك تعرف نفسك خلاك
تتعرف على ثقافه العالم اللي حولك طلعت
انت العاقل في النهايه طيب انا قبل امس
الفجر وصلت السعوديه كنت جاي من الزلزال
اللي صار في تركيا وسوري على الحدود
طبعا التجارب هذه
تخلينا نتقرب من الناس اكثر نتقرب من
الارض اكثر نتقرب من معنى الانسان اكثر
نعرف قيمه الحياه اكثر لذلك انا اذكر في
في 2018 رحنا زلزاله تسونامي وكان زلزال
تسونامي حق اندونيسي اللي صار مؤثر
بالنسبه لي بشكل كبير لانه كنت اسال اقول
متحمس وين القريه اللي طاحت يا جماعه يلا
نبغى ننقذ نبغى ننتشر نبغى نساعد نبغى
فكان يقول القريه ترى تحتك كان اول زلزال
بالنسبه لي احضره في حياه كنت تقول كيف
هذه القريه مش قدام شوي شوف هنا كان في
بيوت شفت الحفره هذي طل طل فعلا في سطح
بيت في سيارات داخله في بعض
عالم مرعب عالم مخيف
في زلزال القرن اللي سموه زلزال القرن
اللي صار في تركيا وروسيا وسوريا عفوا كان
فيه برضو
تجربه بالنسبه لي عظيمه ليش لانه في كل
سفره كنت اتعرف على نفسي اكثر كنت اجد
معنى من وجودي في هذا الحياه اكبر
جماعه الزلزال اللي صار تخيل انك نايم في
بيتك الساعه اربعه الفجر
تقوم ان تحت الركام او تقوم
انت في مكان غير المكان اللي كنت تعرفه او
ما تقوم
انا اعطيكم اعطيكم فكره انه
كيف الوضع وكيف ان العالم فيه بساطه وكيف
ان العالم في تسامح وكيف ان العالم لسه
قاعد يعيش يعني لسه او خليني اخذكم للعالم
ثاني عالم الاطفال خلينا ندخل في الاطفال
الصوره اوضح سامحيني يا دكتوره ساره بدخل
في ملعب
كنت امشي بين الخيام في مدينه اسمها نور
داغي من المدن اللي تضررت بالكامل
فرحت عند احد الاطفال
ناداني قال عمو انت سعودي
فرحت عند الطفل هذا قلت ايوه انا من
السعوديه انت اول ما قال والله بالسعودي
قلت اول مره تشوف حدا سعودي قال ايش شفتكم
على التيك توك بس اول مره بشوف حدا قدامي
بعدين طفل ثاني قال عمو كريستيانو رونالدو
صار عندكم
طبعا كريستيانو رونالدو وقوه ناعم ما احد
يختلف فيها الزلزال المحلات الطايحه والله
العظيم تيشرتات النصر موجود منثره رونالدو
في تركيا وعلى الحدود السوريه فطبعا هناك
الوضع عنده كل واحد
مع الزلزال اللي صار صار ينام فيه خيمته
في خيمه منح منح منحت له او في سياره
سياره صارت اكثر مكان امن هي القصر
بالنسبه لهم اللي عنده سياره محظور
لقيته خيمه لكريستيانو
طبعا هم في بالهم ان الزلزال صار في
العالم كله هم الاطفال اتكلم عن اطفال
مواليد ازمات مواليد حروب يعني الاطفال
الطفل سوري طالع من حرب او طلع واهله من
حرب انولد في الحدود انولد لاجئ فيقول عمو
لقيته لكريستيانو خيمه فواحد ثاني رد عليه
يقول لك ليش خيمه كريستيانو عنده السيارات
اكيد بينام في وحده من سيارات
المشهد او المعنى اللي تعرفنا عليه في في
هذه الازمه انه
الحمد لله يا جماعه احنا قاعدين نعيش في
بلد امن في بلد مستقر لكن هذا مو يعني انه
احنا خلاص محظوظين رب العالمين اصطفانا
ببلد الحرمين الشريفين قيادتنا وفرت لنا
كل الوسائل الامنه نعيش فيها انه خلاص
انتهى الوضع لا في عداله في الكون في
الدين في زكاه ليش في زكاه على اساس انه
الغني يعطي الفقير في مساواه في الكون
فاحنا لازم ان احنا نقدم لازم ان احنا
نعطي لازم احنا الواحد يبغى يتعرف على
نفسه فعلا لازم يتطوع يكتشف نفسك في
الميدان دولي راح اعمل عمل انساني رحت
تطوع اعرف حقيقه نفسك اعرف شخصيتك بره كيف
راح تكون لما تتعامل مع اللايك تعرفون يا
جماعه ترى احنا ما قاعدين نقدم فعليا احنا
قاعدين ناخذ
يمكن اذا في احد موجود اكيد يمكن بعض
الناس شاركوا معي في بعض المهام مخيم
الزعتري انا اخر يوم
دائما اواجه مشكله مع المتطوعين المشكله
اللي اوجهها ان هذا المتطوع اللي جاي
يساعد
اخر يوم هو اللي يبكي واللي قاعد يطبطب
عليه
فعليا الشخص لما يطلع في مثل هذه المهام
ترى يرجع شخص ثاني يرجع يفكر انا وش راح
اقدم في حياتي وش راح اسوي للناس هذه
هل فعلا انا حياتي تستحق اني اني اعيشها
بالطريقه هذه يا اخي انا الدكتور قد
الدنيا يا اخي مبروك احسنت انت في رحله
الحياه ناجح لكن هل انت في رحله البحث على
المعنى هل انت وجدت معنى قيم لحياتك يستحق
ان تعيش لاجله انا ضغطت الكليك بالغلط بس
يلا خلينا دائما ضغطت الكليك هذه
هذه بعض المشاهد كانت في في زلزال تركيا
هذا مثلا الصوره اللي تشوفونها قدامكم
كانوا الناس يحطون صور الضحايا الزلزال
قدام الركام كنوع من تخليد ذكراهم يعني
فهذه لبعض الصور خليني اوريكم صوره ثانيه
هذه اللي على اليمين انا اسميها طفله
الموناليزا لانه لما كنا في اندونيسيا
هذه
عفوا هذا الدميه كانت وين ما اروح كانها
تشوفني كانها تنادينا كنت اقول وين البيوت
قال بيوت تحتك راحت فكانت هذه الدنيا هي
الدميه ناجيه من الزلزال هذه نفس الشيء
اللي صورتها صورتهم في
في
تركيا في الحدود التركيه السوريه لحد
المناطق خليني اوريكم فيديو عشان ما اكثر
عليكم كلام بس عشان تاخذون فكره وتصور عن
الاشياء اللي قاعد تصير بالفيلد بره
شوفوا يا جماعه هذا الطفل اللي بتشوفونه
الان الحكومه التركيه اعلنت ايقاف عمليات
البحث عن
المفقودين تحت الانقاض
لكن الطفل هذا كان ببراءه الاطفال
لا زال يقول انا عمو عم بسمع صوت رفيقي
ابن الجيران هو موجود تحت انا والله شفت
اصبعة يا عمه
هم شالوا اصبع وانا شفتهم شالوا اصبع هو
موجود هون
طبعا هو كان مصر
انتهت عمليات البحث اعلن وخلاص ما عاد في
احد تحت
احنا لما نروح المكان زي هذا ترى مكان هذا
في اوبئه في تجمع جثث في ريحه الدم في في
يعني يعتبر مكان خطير ترى الزلازل كانت
لازلت الى اليوم انا اتكلم في زلازل
مستمره في اليوم يصير 80 90 زلزال في
الحدود هناك
ولا زال هذا الطفل قاعد يبحث عنده امل
وهذا الامل ما راح ادخل في موضوع على انه
جانب نفسي كبير على ماني مختص فيه لكن هذا
عالم اخر ترى يا جماعه الناس تقول الكره
الارضيه هذه مسطحه ولا تدور ما بدخل لكم
في الموضوع هذا موال طويل صح
جيولوجيا ما راح اتكلم بس انا اللي شفته
واللي قاعد يعني يوميا امر فيه اقول
الدنيا تدور الحال في الدنيا هذا قاعد
يدور في ناس عندهم سبع سنين عجاف وفي ناس
عندهم سبع سنين سمعان وفي ناس حياتهم كلها
سنينهم سمان وفي ناس كلها اعجاف
لكن هذا وش يعطينا يعطينا مؤشر ان الحال
ما ما يدوم الواحد لازم يصنع اثر لازم
يترك لنفسه معنى خالد في هذه الحياه ترى
احنا لما نقول الاثر في العمل الانساني
يمكن الناس اللي اشتغلت في الميدان العمل
الان احنا نقول اذا بتسافر ما راح تترك
اثر لا تروح المشروع اذا ما فيه اثر لا
تسويه
عطيت واحد سله وقاعد ياكل وبعدين اليوم
اليوم شبع بكره جعان الا طبعا في فترات
علميه هي فترات العاجله هي فتره انقاذ
حياه
لذلك اصنع لحياتك اثر لحياتك معنا يستحق
ان تعيش لاجله الميدان الانساني دائما
يخليك
يخلق اشياء كثيره من ضمنها يخلق فنانين
بعرض لكم الان مقطع لطفل هو كان يوصف
الازمه خلو الوصف حقي الوصف حقي يمكن وصف
واحد راح من السعوديه وشاف هناك ونقل لكم
وليس من راك من سمع مهما وصفت ما راح
تشوفون لكن هذا مقطع يمكنه اقرب من كلامي
بكثير هذا كان يشرح وش الزلزال اللي صار
هيك المنظر انا رسمته هذه اللي هون هيك
انا رسمته وهون بفعل مدني عم يحفرون مشان
يطالعوا
الانسان يعني من تحت الانقاذ
وهي البنت يعني قاعده بتستنى اهلنا بين ما
يطلعوها من تحت الالقاز وهيك عم بتدلهم
هون هون هون هون هاي بنايتنا هون غرفتنا
هيك
وكمان هذه هون الولد قاعد
اما جايه من هناك
وهذا كمان عم يشيل جثه الفيو بده يحطهم في
الكيس الاسود
هو يفكر نفسه قاعد يقول موقف يعني ترى
تعود عليه بالحرب يمكن شافه يمكن سمع من
من ابوه من امه في البيت تسولف والله
جارنا تعرض للقصف وبالنسبه لو ترى موقف
عادي هو قاعد يتكلم ما يدري انه هو قاعد
يتكلم وهو قاعد يعني
يحزننا كثير على الوضع اللي صاير ويحفزنا
كثير ان احنا فعلا نقدم ونخلي حياتنا لها
قيمه للمثل للناس هذول اللي قاعدين اللي
قاعدين بالفيل الفرصه دائما ان الواحد
يشارك في الخارج ويتطوع وشارك الانسان
دائما مفتوحه لكن انا دائما اقول اربط
حزام الايمان بالله خليك مؤمن بالله خليك
مؤمن في في بلدك وايش قاعده تقدم للعالم
احنا بلد رسالتها انسانيه بلا حدود للعالم
كله
احنا بلد رسالتنا ساميه ونبيله لا تخلي
احد ياثر فيك وين ما تروح دائما افتح منصه
المساعدات الانسانيه حقت مركز الملك سلمان
حط الدوله شوف بلدك وش قدمت لهذا الدوله
على اساس تتسلح بالثقافه تعرف ايش بلدك
قدمت لهذا المكان انا اقول لك هذا على
الصعيد البلد على الصعيد نفسك انطلق في
رحله بحثك عن معناه معنى قيم لحياتك تستحق
ان تعيش لاجله خلي حياتك هذه فيها قيمه
انسانيه نبيله اترك الشهاداتك الجامعيه
وعملك هذا قاعد اتقدم لحياتك لاهلك لكن
خلودك في هذه الحياه هو المعنى الجميل
اللي انت تركته عشان تعيش لاجله عشان
الناس تتكلم فيه بعد ما تمشي اساس الناس
تستفيد منه بعد ما تمشي هو الاثر اللي انت
فعلا صنعته في هذه الحياه
احنا لما نطلع اي ميدان عمل انسان ترى
نواجه مواقف مره في في المانيا في الحدود
الالمانيه كنا نتعامل مع الطالبين اللجوء
جلست فتره ثلاثه شهور مستشار قانوني في
قضايا الطلب اللجوء في الصليب الاحمر
الالماني كيف نخلي الشخص يحصل على اللجوء
اذا كان يستحق هذا اللجوء في وحده من
القصص كان في رجل سوري مبين انه اصلا هو
ضابط عسكري من دخل علينا فكنا انا
والدكتور فرانك دكتور الماني قلنا له احكي
قصتك فكان يحكي قصه يقول والله انا كنت مع
اثنين من اصدقائي احنا عيال الجيران وفي
سوريا الجيران اصلا هم اهلن فانشقوا قالوا
خلينا نشق يلا مشينا نشق وبعدين هم قلت
انا خلاص انا بلحقكم وانتو روحوا مسكوهم
ولما مسكوهم جابوهم قالوا انت ليش ما
انشقيت معاهم قلت لا انا ما عندي توجهاتك
قالوا اثبت هذا السلاح اقتلهم
فجاه هذا الرجل الضخم نهار قاعد يبكي
دكتور فرانك يقول اساله عشان الترجمه
بساله قتلهم
فكنت اقول له طبعا في الله الحق انه ياخذ
بريك حتى لو كان في المقابل الرسميه ابدا
فاساله قتلهم
فكنت اقول
قتلتهم صح بس هز لي راسك
طبعا هز اللي راسه ابو بكر واعطينا وقت
وطلع شوي وبعدين وكملنا في قصته يبغى يحصل
على اللجوء بس عشان اهله مخبيهم تحت بيت
واحد من اصدقائه في سوريا بس يبغى يجيبهم
شوفوا العالم ايش قاعد يصير فيه ترى هذا
في نفس الكره الارضيه اللي احنا قاعدين
نعيش فيها ترى ما هو بمكان بعيد
ترى في عداله في الكون احنا موجودين برضو
لابد مثل ما في زكاه في المال ترى في زكاه
في العلم في زكاه في العمل
الناس هذه لها حق علينا
ولما اقول لك رحله البحث عن المعنى
اعتبروني شباك تذاكر بعطيكم تذاكر ابحثوا
عن رحلتكم انطلقوا في رحلتكم خلي حياتك
فيها معنى لمثل هذه الناس انك قدمت للعالم
اللي حولك لكل الناس اللي حولك مش بس
لاهلك وابنائك
ترى هذه فترتنا
فطرتنا وهذه عاداتنا وهذا ديننا قبل كل
شيء هذا تقاليدنا انا لما اقول معنا ما
اتكلم عن المعنى العقدي العقدي واضح وما
خلقت الجن والانسى الا ليعبدون انا اتكلم
عن معنى قيم نبيل في حياتك ادعوكم اعتذر
على الاطاله وادعو كل شخص فيكم انه يبحث
عن معنى قيم يضيفه لحياته الثمينه التي
يستحق ان يعيشها شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]